nous qu'il y avait d'abord peur que la
prochaine étape des lignes si vous
m'écoutez à travers cette vidéo aujourd'hui
cela signifie que je n'ai pas pu faire la
conférence de presse que j'avais prévue pour
le 11 avril mais je voulais vous dire
l'essentiel  du message que je
voulais développer le 11 avril et
j'espère répondre à tant de questions que
je suis sûr que vous avez en tête
le premier message est je suis innocent ce n'est
pas nouveau vous l'avez entendu de moi
en janvier je le répète  aujourd'hui, je suis
innocent de toutes les accusations qui ont
été portées contre moi et je suis également
innocent de toutes les accusations qui
ont entouré ces accusations qui sont toutes biaisées,
sorties de leur contexte, tordues de manière à
peindre un personnage de cupidité et de
personnage de dictature je reste sur
la même position j'ai passé 108 jours en
prison car j'ai toujours été
cohérent avec cette position que j'étais
innocent de toutes les accusations le deuxième
message que je veux vous envoyer est le fait
que j'aime le Japon et je  aime Nissa  n
personne ne passe 20 ans dans un pays
personne ne travaille 20 ans à la tête
d'une entreprise sans amour et sans
attachement et sans engagement
surtout quand ces années ont été
marquées par tant d'accomplissement et
tant de résultat je suis venu au Japon en 1999 non
par calcul  Je suis venu au Japon en 1999
parce que j'étais fasciné par le
pays et j'étais fasciné par le
défi de relancer Nissan et vous
savez très bien que j'ai consacré depuis
le début toute ma carrière à la
réussite du plan de relance Nissan maintenant
mon amour pour le Japon  et mon amour pour Nissan
est intact aujourd'hui le troisième point je
veux vous dire qu'il s'agit d'un
complot il s'agit d'un complot il s'agit
d'un complot il s'agit de l'
estomac arrière c'est de cela que nous parlons
pourquoi afin que nous puissions dire pourquoi cela s'est produit  pourquoi
c'est arrivé parce qu'il y avait d'abord
peur que la prochaine étape des lignes en
termes de convergence et en termes d'évolution
vers la fusion ne
menace d'une certaine manière certaines personnes  le ou éventuellement
menacer l'autonomie de Nissan qui
d'ailleurs n'a jamais été
menacée depuis 19 ans quand les lignes ont été
créées je veux dire le plus farouche défenseur de
l'autonomie de Nissan et j'ai
bien précisé que peu importe les autres
étapes de la  à l'avenir cela continuerait
mais cette autonomie doit être basée sur la
performance donc la performance de Nissan
n'est pas bonne elle s'est beaucoup dégradée trois
avertissements sur bénéfices en quelques années de nombreux
scandales pas le fait que de mauvaises choses
se produisent au niveau de l'entreprise mais
le  fait que lorsque vous réagissez aux mauvaises
choses qui se passent dans votre entreprise, vous
devez faire confiance et dans ce cas, dans de nombreux
cas, on ne pouvait pas lui faire confiance parce que
l'entreprise a déclaré que le problème était le poisson là où
il n'était pas résolu, c'est là que nous avons eu
un problème avec le  gestion réelle
de l'entreprise, donc ces personnes sont
connues, ce qui signifie que nous ne parlons pas de
j'ai beaucoup de respect pour les
employés de Nissan, je parle ici de quelques
cadres qui évidemment  y pour leur propre
intérêt et pour leurs propres peurs égoïstes
créent beaucoup de noms de destruction de valeur
vous les connaissez nous parlons de
gens qui ont vraiment joué un jeu très sale
sur ce qui se passe mais
j'espère que la vérité se produira et les
faits se produiront  mais en fin de
compte pendant toute cette période
j'ai souffert non seulement à cause de mon cas
mais qui s'occupait de Nissan
qui s'occupait de la marque qui
défendait la valeur de l'entreprise
qui défendait l'intérêt des actionnaires
quand vous regardez le  baisse de l'
action quand on regarde les
performances absolument médiocres de l'entreprise
où les gens sont fiers de dire on
va pas faire ça on va pas faire
ça mais en même temps ils ne
te disent pas ce qu'on  allaient faire quelle
est la vision pour l'avenir quelle est la
vision pour améliorer les performances de
Nissan très triste et évidemment pour
quelqu'un comme moi c'est écœurant
pour quelqu'un qui a consacré 19 20 ans
à faire le c  au contraire ce qui crée la
valeur de l'entreprise valorise la marque vu
le manque de saison et le manque d'
attention c'est vraiment très difficile à
encaisser mais aussi